So it's pretty clear that if you were raising around to capital, going to friends and family
or crowdfunding like Kickstarter or angel capital or venture capital or corporate partners,
all kind of make sense for financing.
Also, going to the small business administration or getting SBIR grants
also fit into the financing column.
But for operating capital that is money you need when your company is an ongoing concern
in generating revenue--well, lease lines make sense, factoring, vendor financing.
And what's really interesting is you might also get operating capital from government grants as well
and corporate partners that are also fit there.
So there's two actually went into the correct category.
Well, surprisingly of course venture capital always does follow on rounds
so this was kind of a trick question.
You could always get more operating capital in subsequent rounds
from venture capitalist, not on the corporate partners.
Just remember that VCs will invest more money to get more ownership of your company.